irrespective of the decision that the
people in the United Kingdom have taken
to leave the European Union we are
linked by very close bonds of friendship
of partnership our two countries have
always acted on a bases are very clear
and firm and similar convictions we
share the same values and this in many
ways also determines how we deal with
present challenges we're partners in
NATO we will both of us be in attendance
at the g20 meeting in China where
members of g7 and obviously the
relationship this will determine the
relationship and also the spirit in
which we will carry out the negotiations
on the United Kingdom leaving the
European Union irrespective of this
process and independently of this
process of leaving the European Union we
want to also continue to foster our
relations on the economic field in the
political phoebus assess ever after all
in our mutual interest Germany and
Britain have always cooperated very
closely within the European Union and I
very much hope that this is the spirit
with which we will continue to pursue
those negotiations right from the start
I said after the referendum was decided
that it is now up to the British
government to define how it wishes to
see it's a future relationship with the
European Union and to then also pursue
the following steps as particularly as
regards the process leading up to the
two invoking article 50 only then will
the proper negotiation start the
treaties of the European Union very
clear on this